[Music]
i'm an idiot
it's showtime
i don't deserve these powers if i'm
being honest like what am i even
contributing
wow there's already a superhero with a
red suit with a lightning bolt on it
aquaman is literally huge and he's so
manly and batman is so cool and i'm
just me
[Music]
i feel like a fraud
it doesn't matter um anyway the wizard
gave me super powers
and then everybody got super powers was
everyone going
to fight crime
okay
now everyone's kind of like doing their
own thing and i'm the only one trying to
keep it together
you understand i'm a pediatrician
right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
look i might not have as much experience
as you because i'm not super old like
you but i've seen all of the fast and
furious movies lady it's all about
family
family guys that was a signal
introducing the star of our show
his name is
[Music]
you think i know how to fix this dude
but i really don't
can be worthy
let's give it a chance
now go fight for your family go fight
for the world
[Music]
i just threw a truck at a dragon i love
my life
[Music]